this is keep Beach City weird I'm ready
to piss off some fancy I did not like
this episode you go first
oh this is um I fit you know I didn't
think I would dislike a character more
than Lars
this is gotta be the most annoying and I
get it that's the point it's a
conspiracy but I mean he's annoying the
idea of the episodes annoying yeah I
think what they do at the end is kind of
like the island episode where it just
seems totally unfounded thank you not a
good idea
Emily oh my god okay I thought that you
know looking with yessing he is his
conspiracy theories going which are not
good or healthy you know helpful yeah
but not helpful but you know okay if
like I kind of get what maybe they're
going for it for like okay some people
are just gonna be in their own little
world and you know if there's really no
harm in Leh than be in that world let
them be in that world and it's like even
then I always had to bait that sometimes
but it's like I see the argument I see
the idea this guy fucking kidnaps a kid
is gonna do God knows what - Levi I
swear to God I was drugged with Doug it
was like watch it's gonna go all fucking
frailty on us he's like no kill the
snake first and then at the end of all
demons inside it and they at the end
they're like no no let's give him some
more conspiracies cuz you know I don't
keep him happy I'm like no this is
fuckin awful this guy that's right a
possible murderer and it's like swear I
love he let's see to me the only thing
this episode really just fuckin nailed
is what these people are hell it's just
even humanity what that lion pearl said
which was just oh that's some dibelius
is like they all want line common enemy
to fight instead of a high school that
ya symbol instead of realizing that you
know life is a series of you know
interrelated events that I probably
can't really do anything about or
control cuz they're the others yeah
that's it that that we can't control
them at this life it's sad but also kind
of funny ya know honestly everybody what
line is like I'm like okay can we just
crap the rest of the episode and Jesse
if you just show me that line I'd be
like I'm good those only five seconds
but I'm gonna like that was such a
well-written line I just don't have any
toleration for conspiracy theory types I
know well in the become like she's good
I'm like bullshit meter that's one of
the ones that will piss me off really
fast you get into that you get your
religious zealots I have little
toleration for that either and they're
funny because they have similar
personalities yeah one likes to blame it
all on conspiracies and other blames at
all on God but you know or the devil
yeah uh but yeah it's just one of those
things where it's like they're purposely
obviously trying to make this guy very
unlikable and very annoying so we don't
want to see him get his happy ending at
the end uh and on top of that if I had
to guess I would think that they've
either come across a lot of people like
this or one particular person and
they're like again kind of like well
they nailed it so well that did yeah
it's like he's so unlikable but she
that's what that's what bothered me
about the ending cuz I'm they so nailed
it and I'm like okay well maybe that'll
be like maybe there'll be some point to
this and then they I thought the ending
kind of just jettison that a bit so I'm
like okay I don't know what the hell'd
is unless I mean maybe this is some
setup maybe he comes back again and
again and is throwing a random okay I
just say I I so did not I didn't enjoy
the voice I didn't enjoy the design I'd
enjoy what he did I mean nothing about
him was enjoyable and every time he was
on screen I mean I'm just sitting there
like it's the first time I think you
were checking your phone I was checking
the time I could dive in toning out
whatever it's time these mere whatever
ten fifteen minutes uh felt very long I
mean I was just like oh my god cans yeah
be over uh and and it's so weird cuz
it's like I see more annoying stuff in
my life and you know I mean on the grand
scale things that like piss me off or
annoying and stuff I mean this is this
episodes one of them know it here
because you like those type of
characters yeah it's not entertaining
it's not enlightening the only
enlightening thing like I said is that
one line which which was beautifully put
but could it be in a better episode or
better
sure I hated it as much as you but I'm
very man I I just like you said I think
just why why give us this character why
I mean we know they exist we know
they're annoying and it dies bring it
like comments like a week from now when
this goes up and like you have no idea
the entire season engine could you just
make him more interesting or just
likeable or just something that would
like you know make me go ahead myself in
the second episode appearance with the
killings band suddenly it all comes
together with that I never I never write
anything off on this show I I would be
very impressed if they somehow made that
character like very likable very
essential to the plot and like maybe
where I could go back to this episode be
like you know now I get it
and this episode was secretly genius um
yeah I mean there's and don't give it
run there's definitely times where I
really respect uh when either a show or
a movie or some form of art or something
like that is trying to piss you off and
they have like some sort of grand scheme
around it you know Eddie Kaufman did
that a lot there's a lot of artists
they've done that uh but yeah this is a
case where I'm just like yeah I don't
feel that same cleverness behind it I
don't feel we could have listened to 15
minutes of Great Gatsby being read the
suspicious
afraid we'll have enjoyed that board at
least its Great Gatsby but yeah big
Great Gatsby fan but okay how do I put
at least I could study why this is
considered a classic and why people love
it I get why it's considered a classic I
just I don't like a lot of people that
was the one book in high school they're
like no I liked that when I was one of
the ones I was like yeah
that was kind of different to it to us I
did but can't be bad as Tess of the
d'Urbervilles I did that one that one I
never read but wearying off-topic uh but
that's yeah I I don't know I I can't say
I was like oh this anger to be your
stuff I was just so not interested and I
think for you know for Steven universe
they have an episode where you're not
interested it's like that's tough to do
it's tough to have such a strange
scenario and just make it so not
interests
and little learned um and not really
that good immoral if anything I say a
very bad more um but yeah again I say
that's kind of two episodes we've come
across that I'm really like man what are
these L know these have like some weird
agendas or something then this one the
island episode they'll have the island
episode I'd say I kind of liked uh you
know until it got to like them yeah this
yen this one just one begin no we think
such a Steven tank I love Steven tango
was gonna door a Steven tag uh idea and
seeing them you know seeing guarded boys
come out of that Steven but any that
that was funny that was neat I wanted to
see more of that uh yeah as soon as that
guy came in whatever he was on screen
that really was it it's like when he
came in it was bad than when he left it
kind of got good again with a great
analysis of what he was and then when he
came back it got bad again and it's just
yeah I think I found probably my most
unlikable character of this show so
sorry to whoever created him or voice
acting or whatever but yeah just uh not
a fan sorry
oh but who knows maybe he'll be the most
likable character by the time the series
wraps up or something who knows oh yeah
have nothing much to say yeah so there
it is sorry if we sorry this is like the
most likable character to some people I
I just couldn't stand them uh but uh
there is you're not always gonna him for
you know he's gonna hit perfection but
uh well I mean you're living proof of
that
exactly um ouch no I'm sorry
I don't think you are no you're right
I'm not
stills and feels bad as watching this
episode that I am sorry for that was me
I still love Steven universe it's a good
show can we just get to the next one
yeah yeah let's see the next one
really what was up with this episode